it's time to reveal the honest truth
about andrew tate i want to tell you who
he is based on my personal experiences
with him i've actually met andrew on
several occasions the first time i met
him was in 2020 so two years ago we met
in romania in bucharest through a mutual
friend and we all went out for dinner
together he turned up in a lambo which
was pretty cool um he was there with his
girlfriend i was there with some friends
and we all had dinner and we all had a
really really nice time we spoke a lot
about crypto we spoke a lot about covid
we spoke a lot about all the crazy
things that are going on in the world at
the moment he asked me my opinion on it
we had a really nice intellectual
conversation he wasn't rude to me he
wasn't inappropriate with me and he was
very gentlemanly and very friendly we
then ordered some food he said please
order anything you like he was very
polite and friendly to the waiters and
waitresses which i think is also a sign
of somebody's character he got the bill
which was very generous it was obviously
going to be very expensive we ordered
wine meats starters dessert we had a
really great time